The jogan Experience Tucker Carlson had
this uh guy who used to work for a
pharmaceutical company on uh his show
today or the episodes out today and it's
about a lot of it is about OIC about how
many people are being prescribed OIC are
they're handing it out like nothing too
it's kind of wild it's kind of wild
because it's I think it's it's going to
be one of the most profitable drugs ever
do they you know what's going to happen
to you after you take it cuz people have
been taking it I got a feeling there's
no way that works that's what I'm dude
people have been taking it for a long
time they're like well we've used this
for diabetes I felt that way about
literally every single I know dude dude
SSR like people were like you you're
depressed I was like yeah dude
definitely like take this I'm like no
they're terrible they turned out to be
awful dude the withdrawal from those
things are catastrophic people have
severe bio uh intestinal sort of things
happen with them with the if they have a
bad side effect gastrointestinal numbs
your genitals you can get numb genitals
too Brian Simpson had a real bad
reaction to it really yeah real bad that
sucks Brian said yeah his stomach was
just
jacked but some people have it some
people take it it's no problem at all
yeah but when you try to get off of them
it's like you have like a headache and
brain zaps for like a month what what
are you w Jamie and a can't zic burned
off my genitals I found pieces of
charred skin in the toilet maybe maybe
some other things are going on yeah
[__]
OIC Is that real yor I mean New York
Post posted it um Dr Maria's [__] fell
off oh my God she got severe burns and
charred skin on her vagina anus and
butocks owing to Once weekly Jabs she's
a professor of
pharmacology health and uh pharmacology
Health at the University of uh Texas Rio
Grand Valley penned a testimony on her
OIC used to news so she's obviously very
smart yeah just OIC tow that [__] up
that's aw oh my God she said I check my
genitals my boyfriend's name is
ozanic that's just ozanic
man [__] rocked my anus my anus fell
off I took a [__] my anus fell off God
damn it she said some areas had charred
skin fine she said it was if she was
exposed to sunlight for days yo Jes why
she taking those out she's she's cuz
everybody wants to be skinny man she
looks great and dude everyone's on I
know a lot of people going on this stuff
like bro can you imagine no no I'm not
talking about this particular woman sure
but if you brought home a lady mhm and
she had a charred anus and
vagina you're like what happened I used
to be fat you'd go all right she's thin
and hot now here's a picture of me when
I was 250 like whoa how'd you do this oh
zic my butt fell off but things are fine
we could do other stuff yeah do mouth
[Laughter]
play my holes fell off my holes are R my
[__] holes fell off but it's fine are
you into mouth play mouth
play sorry bro I know that's not great
but saying mouth play and hand play it's
so funny what a side effect what are you
[__] Google what you do Jamie way I
just keep going down the article and the
way still hurts when have to urinate or
defecate it often starts peeling again
because of the friction said the
Survivor they're calling her Survivor
this might be the her lawyer might have
wrote all those on a very strict diet
not taking any medication at this moment
in time but this will change in a few
weeks Ros ATA I want to heal before I
start again with any medication and due
to the strict diet my level of glucose
is thankfully under control
friction she still supports it which is
nice she still laws the injections for
lowering her blood sugar well that's
what it's for right it's a diabetes drug
damn that's [__] wild I think one of
the side effects is like stomach
paralysis or something like that she had
all of the side effects you guys just
said depression Gastro and gastro
problems I'd be depressed yeah yeah
that's dude that's [__] up yeah it's a
weird thing man because it's like yeah
you shouldn't be obese and I think it's
something like 50% of the country chain
speak on this speak on your people [__]
you
Joe